bonjour merci d'être avec nous pour ce
premier débat des élections
départementales de la voie est libre
quatre départements bourguignons quatre
débats en commençant aujourd'hui par la
nièvre département hautement symbolique
pour la gauche française longtemps
présidé par françois mitterrand jamais
pris par la droite même dans les pires
tempêtes politiques de ces dernières
décennies
un débat que nous vous proposons en
partenariat avec le journal du centre et
son rédacteur en chef et avec moi
bonjour jean philippe darphin
bonjour ligue 1 et chez vous comme
d'habitude vous pouvez réagir sur
internet sur les réseaux sociaux vous
avez déjà poser vos remarques et vos
questions sur ce plateau donc avec nous
patrice joly le président socialiste du
conseil général de la nièvre
bonjour bonjour pascal de mauraige vous
présidez le groupe d'opposition de
droite au conseil général bonjour à vous
françois diot pour le parti communiste
bonjour françois diot marcel stéphan
pour le front national
bonjour bonjour et gilles maury ni pour
les candidatures nièvre à venir bonjour
bonjour je précise que vous êtes tous
candidats sur des cantons différents de
la nièvre mais que nous allons débattre
au niveau du département
les cantons justement c'est à des
changements de cette élection avec un
redécoupage il y avait trente deux
cantons il n'y en a plus que 17 qui
auront chacun un binôme de conseillers
départementaux un homme une femme
ce qui fera au final et c'est une
originalité de la nièvre plus de
conseillers dans l'hémicycle 34 et avant
de nous pencher sur la suite
après les élections c'est le moment
d'examiner d'abord le bilan des sortants
et patrice joly forcément c'est à vous
que s'adresse la première question
de quoi êtes vous fier que
regrettez-vous fier d'avoir représenté
la nièvre représentée à travers la
nièvre l'ensemble des territoires ruraux
on a beaucoup parlé au cours de ces
dernières années trop peut-être d'un
avenir de la france qui reposerait
uniquement sur les métropoles
c'est une erreur de penser ça certes les
métropoles ont toute leur place pour
pouvoir construire l'avenir participer à
la construction de l'avenir de notre
pays mais la france qui a le plus bel
espace rural en europe
on pourra y revenir et revenir bien sûr
se doit d'en tirer parti c'est un
avantage cet atout salle avantage
compétitif dans la compétition interne
sonal l'avenir des espaces ruraux
l'avenir de la france passe aussi par
l'avenir des espaces ruraux
pascal de mauraige le bilan que dresse
l'opposition conseil général forcément
je ne vais pas de vercors vous en doutez
moi je mettrais en opposition quand même
une baisse notoire de la population des
fermetures de classes et je crois que là
on nous allons encore en vivre
quelques-unes 20 postes en bourgogne
dont 12 dans la nièvre
une population qui est en augmentation
dans les trois autres départements
bourguignons mais pour la nièvre une un
taux de pauvreté supérieur à la moyenne
nationale
et puis quand même un quart de nos
jeunes de 18 à 25 ans qui sont sans
formation et sans emploi et puis je
pense qu'on peut aussi parler d'un
désenclavement qui n'a pas été aboutie
on peut regretter qu'en son temps il ya
eu des opportunités et qu'elles n'ont
pas été saisis pour débloquer 7 à 77 qui
est un petit peu comme l'arlésienne
voilà d'autres choses une politique
touristique peut être économique et
touristique trop ciblé peut à notre goût
pour certains secteurs le morvan bien
sûr qui est cher au président actuel est
peut-être magny cours où comprimant
d'autres territoires et venir monsieur
jolie vous avez parlé des nouvelles
ruralités au certains de vos
contradicteurs vous reprocheront
justement cette association de ruralité
et de nièvre puisqu'il ya aussi une
partie urbaine
je pense notamment l'agglomération de
nevers qu'est ce que vous répondez 1
cela en de manière très simple ceux qui
s'interrogent veulent caricaturer ma
manière de penser notre territoire
quand je dis que l'avenir de la france
ne passe pas que par les métropoles et
que les territoires ruraux ils ont toute
leur place et peuvent apporter plus que
l'on pense non seulement pour leur
développement mais au redressement de
notre pays
j'inclus bien évidemment tous les
espaces qui ne sont pas métropolitains
les dix ou douze métropole qu'on évoque
régulièrement c'est-à-dire 5les
s'intègrent bien évidemment les chefs
lieux de département nevers son
agglomération mais aussi le nos villes
plus petites telles que clamecy la
charité caunes et et les autres c'est ça
en fait derrière ce concept de nouvelle
ruralité c'est tout ce qui n'est pas
métropolitain
et qu'il serait dommage de laisser de
côté en tout cas nous nous avons décidé
de porter le fer en quelque sorte et de
témoigner de la capacité qu'ont nos
territoires a participé à leur
développement à travers ce qu'on appelle
l'économie verte une économie qui n'est
pas délocalisable nous disposons des
espaces nous y disposons de ressources
naturelles l'eau l'air les produits
forestiers les productions agricoles
autant d'éléments qui constituent ce
économie verte créatrice potentiellement
de plus en plus encore que ce que l'on
constate aujourd'hui on est allé très
vite finalement à la fois sur la vision
du département et sur le bilan mais tout
ça se recoupent on le comprend d'une
certaine manière
françois diot votre vision vous vous
aviez un élu au conseil général jusqu'à
la fin de cette cette mandature
votre vision de l'action de la majorité
et d'une certaine manière lié à cette
vision du département l'état du
département
on a un est un département qui souffre
6000 emplois industriels supprimés
depuis 2008
14000 personnes inscrites à pôle emploi
toutes catégories confondues 19% de la
population sous le seuil de pauvreté etc
etc
ça c'est pas le résultat exclusif de la
politique menée par patrice joly comme
le diront sans doute les candidats de
droite et puis le front national sur sur
ce plateau
mais c'est le résultat d'orientation qui
sont insuffisamment combattue par
patrice joly et part et par son équipe
c'est à dire les logiques d'austérité
qui tuent des départements comme le
nôtre et puis les logiques de
métropolisation qui sont celles du
gouvernement actuel qui a créé 14
grandes métropoles etc etc et donc le
parti socialiste aujourd'hui dans le
dans le département n'est pas dans la
résistance et dans le combat mais
davantage dans l'adaptation je prends
quelques exemples les bureaux de poste
on à 72 bureaux de poste qui ont été
transformés en agences postales
communales et s'est passé comme une
lettre à la poste sans jeu de mots à la
commission départementale de présence
postale communale dirigée par un conseil
général socialiste pour l'industrie 150
emplois supprimés à en vis de 6,1 et 477
milles euros de crédit d'impôt
compétitivité emplois touchés par cette
même entreprise
je pense que le président du conseil
général devrait exiger le
remboursement parents vis de ces 477
milles euros pareil pour la nisa il
détient sur ce sujet faute de s'attaquer
à ces logiques d'austérité assez logique
de métropolisation du territoire la
nièvre continuera de péricliter donc on
a besoin d'élus de combat d'élus de
résistance et qu'ils fassent valoir
d'autres choix au niveau national marcel
stéphan votre vision du de l'action du
conseil général venir sur le chômage et
la précarité de certains os que on se
rend compte aujourd'hui c'est bon il ya
d'autres problèmes aussi dans l'avenir
déjà qu'il faut se projeter pour nos
aînés des maisons de retraite
principalement qui sont des lieux
d'hébergement
c'est compliqué pour certains
aujourd'hui falloir vraiment améliorer
la situation
vous considérez que dans les compétences
du conseil général ça n'a pas été
correctement fait jusqu'à non parce que
je suis souvent dans les maisons de
retraite et c'est vrai que les gens qui
sont hébergés pourrait attendre un petit
peu plus surtout bon les retraites
aujourd'hui vous le savez avec 800 900
euros de retraite et payer une pension
de 2000 euros ça devient quasiment
impossible donc je pense qu'il va faire
réellement se pencher sur ce problème
dans l'avenir surtout que les retraités
dans nos départements ça va être en
constante augmentation dans les années
qui viennent
ça c'est ce problème des aînés qui va
falloir traiter anticipées et puis si on
veut revenir un petit peu sur les
nouvelles ruralités je prends un exemple
pour que les élèves et les
téléspectateurs comprennent bien
on parle des transports scolaires de
rediriger les transports colère vers la
campagne plutôt que de la campagne vers
la ville ce qui veut dire que les
nouvelles ruralités c'est les anciennes
ruralité c'est remettre des écoles dans
les campagnes voilà je pense que là il
ya un constat
bon y'a pas que ce problème des
transports scolaires les circuits courts
tout ça c'est l'ancien ruralité donc
c'est un constat d'échec à mon avis je
dis bonjour votre nom est connu dans la
nièvre à une chef d'entreprise
simplement
contrairement à l'ensemble des candidats
qui sont ces plateaux mais je suis je
suis pas un professionnel de la
politique c'est ce que j'allais vous
vous avez restions que j'allais vous
posez un jeu réussi en toute humilité
j'ai aucune prétention
une ambition politique je vis par mon
métier je ne veux pas vivre par la
politique par contre j'ai l'emploi vous
souhaitez pas être élue je n'ai pas
d'ambition pardon geste politique non
mais la formule pourrait prêter mais non
j'ai de l'ambition pour mon territoire
j'ai envie d'être utile à mon
département c'est pour ça que je suis
ici et je me présente je vais revenir
on va peut-être laissé répondre à gilles
mourier d'abord sur le bilan risque on
les voit sur le bilan alors tu sais
peut-être que l'expérience j'avoue que
monsieur jolie vous aurez un certain
talent pour essayer trouver les
arguments pour convaincre les gens d'un
bilan positif
vous ne peut pas faire comme les
gouvernements successifs qui se cachent
ou qui jouent l'héritage vous ça fait 40
ans voire 50 ans vous êtes à la tête du
département et que votre gestion
socialiste emmené irrémédiablement le
département de la nièvre dans une
spirale de déclin du déclin économique
déclin
démographique et déclin social juste un
exemple parce que moi mon métier mon
activité est proche du bâtiment du trot
public et c'est un bon baromètre pour
l'économie locale ou d'un département en
france en 2012 2013
c'est près de 70% de construction de
chute de la construction neuve
je crois que le seul département qui a
fait pire c'est la corse
donc quand on compare effectivement la
nièvre aux autres départements aux
départements qui sont comparables en
tant que nombre david d'habitants moins
de 250 milles à 19 je crois en france on
s'aperçoit que le lièvre c'est plus de
budget est pourtant plus de dépenses
moins de résultats on a le record des
dépenses par rapport au nombre
d'habitants
on va vraiment pas très joli à tout ça
une petite quand même remarque pascal de
mauraige ou six parce que vous aviez
parlé moins que sur ce chapitre là nous
avions d'abord et ensuite c'est
finalement compteur où on récolte une
note de 1 sur 20 à l'argus des
départements on peut pas quand même être
très satisfaits de cette note
forcer la note que l'on nous attribue
pour le département de la nièvre
bon il ya d'autres départements qui ont
les mêmes caractéristiques que nous et
finalement en dépensant 40 millions de
moins il faut sinon mieux au moins
autant alors effectivement je rejoins
les propos de monsieur en disant nous ne
sommes finalement pas si bon que ça
parce que quand j'entends les shows je
me demande si en fait les autres
candidats les représentants en tout cas
des eaux famille politique notre
département
moi je crois foncièrement ce département
il faut distinguer ce qui relève du
territoire départemental avec ses
difficultés qui sont propres qui sont
liées à une histoire des
caractéristiques économiques avec une
population qui est ce qu'elle est et il
y a à côté de ça ce que fait conseil
général pour essayer de construire ou
participer à la construction de l'avenir
de notre département mais permettez moi
de manière préalable évoqué on parle de
professionnels de la politique moi je ne
suis pas un professionnel de la
politique monsieur maureen et j'ai eu
une activité professionnelle
jusqu'à il ya quatre ans et si
d'aventuré les choses le nécessitent et
je reprendrai mon activité
professionnelle
je suis conscient chambre régionale des
comptes j'exerçais le contrôle des
comptes des collectivités locales de
pendant plus de 20 ans et je serai prêt
à y retourner
je ne vis pas de ça et pour aller au
delà c'est un effort personnel pour moi
que d'être ici en tant qu'élu sur mon
département
ce n'est pas un effort sur le plan de
l'intérêt parce que vraiment si je suis
là c'est parce que je crois à mon
département et je m'en viens
effectivement qu'il avance et j'ai
surtout envie de lutter concept fou
contre cette sinistrose
cette résignation cette auto
dévalorisation l'héritage de 50 ans de
40 ans j'entends ça on l'entend depuis
des années ça n'est pas une réalité
le conseil général vous savez comment il
a évolué en cinquante ans il y avait
trois agents du conseil général en 1964
quand françois mitterrand était
président du conseil général
il ya eu depuis mais vous le savez
peut-être pas des lois de
décentralisation qui ont confié des
compétences au conseil général qui
essayent aujourd'hui d exercer au mieux
et puis pour terminer il ya quatre ans
que je suis président du conseil général
et je crois qu'à ma manière j'ai apporté
je crois une autre un autre modèle une
autre manière j'ai complété ce qui
pourrait se faire jusqu'à maintenant à
la fois sur la manière dont on travaille
sur nos cantons sur on travaille sur le
département et que l'on travaille
également à porter ce territoire en être
l'ambassadeur au niveau des ruralités et
des nouvelles ruralités parce que moi je
je ressens et je comprend effectivement
ce que constitue ce sentiment parfois
d'abandon qu'il ya dans les espaces
ruraux et j'y vais pas simplement pour
quémander
j'y vais pour faire partager à
l'ensemble des responsables nationaux
qu'ils soient politiques et soit
économies qu'ils soient médiatique
l'intérêt que représente pour la france
cet espace rural incomparable qu'est
l'espace chorale français et je crois
qu'il n'ya pas peut-être non c'est en
tout cas dans ces dernières années dans
ce département de meilleur défenseur de
notre département et de notre espace
rural en général que cette majorité
départementale je vous coupe patrice
joly pour avancer sur alors une plus
petite réponse
je pense que ces lanières
je veux avoir un élan une de nos
missions économiques
on ne peut pas tout miser sur la réalité
certes nous avons la chance de la nièvre
se découpent moitié à 50% par des zones
rurales 50% des zones urbaines
mais depuis soixante-quatre que vous
avez pris enfin que le parti socialiste
a pris les manettes les commandes du
département on a perdu 30 mille
habitants c'est quand même pas mal c'est
une ré une ville quasiment comme une
affaire qui a disparu de la carte on
peut pas tout miser de la nièvre si on
veut qu'elle compte efficacement dans la
région et puis à fortiori dans la grande
région qui est qui se veulent se fera
bientôt il faut la prendre pour la
nièvre comme un tout pas uniquement dans
son monde rural
je vous confie gilles marini parce que
justement sur ce sujet on avait envie de
vous poser une question à partir d'un
travail qui a été fait comme journal du
centre justement jean philippe oui nous
avons consulté il ya il ya quelques
quelques semaines nos lecteurs pour leur
demander un peu ce qu'ils souhaitaient
pour la nièvre et parmi les soins il ya
le retour du grand prix de formule-1
magny cours au-delà de l'aspect sportif
c'est pas aussi un symbole de la nièvre
qui gagne ce retour là on n'est pas dans
les ruralité justement je vous prie
pascal de mauraige
ça vous semble une bonne idée pourquoi
pas mais pas dans les conditions
auxquelles ça s'est passé
pardonnez moi ma question est double est
ce que ça vous semble une bonne idée en
termes d'image pour la nièvre puisqu'on
vient de dire il faut pas parler que de
la ruralité est ce que ça vous semble
une bonne idée en termes financiers en
termes de moyens dans l'intervention des
collectivités en termes d'image
ok très bien mais en termes de d'aspect
financier je pense que nous avons nous
avons toujours décrié au sein du conseil
général notre groupe en tout cas la
façon dont se passer ces gros prix est
ce que ça coûtait haut nivernais pour
les mettre en place donc penser que le
jeu n'en vaut pas la chandelle
on peut on peut se le demander par
contre nous avons toujours été très très
favorable aux pôles de magny cours en ce
qui concernait toutes les
infrastructures qui s'y rattachent
françois diot même question finalement
images moyen sur ce sujet là le problème
c'est que l'état a déjà dit qu'il ne
mettrait pas un kopeck dans
l'organisation du grand prix de formule
1 et donc je crois que c'est 20 millions
d'euros qui de d'aménagement de
modernisation tiré par le conseil
général ces dernières années c'est
effectivement des compétences qui ne
devrait pas être exclusivement porté par
les collectivités locales mais aussi
peut-être parler grand argentier de la
formule 1 que m'ont dit bernie
ecclestone et c'est donc avant de fermer
l'hôpital de château chinon avant de
fermer des classes avant de supprimer un
des bureaux de poste
voilà je pense qu'il faut déjà répondre
à ces besoins là avant 2 avant de
dépenser l'argent dans un grand prix de
formule 1 ceci dit le circuit
actuellement il existe il ya énormément
d'argent et le public qui est qui a été
investi là-dedans
il ne sert pas qu'aux grands prix de
formule 1 loin de là il sert à 3 se
croit qu'il ya 300 jour d'occupation par
an donc c'est à ça qu'il est utile c'est
pas forcément qu'en formule mention de
fierté et d'image quand même dans dans
ce que disait jean philippe c'est à dire
si les gens auront envie aussi que ça
existe c'est aussi parce qu'ils ont
envie d'avoir chez eux quelque chose car
un retentissement international connu
enfin il ya cette part importante ce que
vous parlez on parle depuis tout à
l'heure de des difficultés du
débarquement
bientôt les moyens en or at on les
moyens disons que l'abandon du grand
prix de formule 1 c'est très symbolique
de l'abandon par les niveaux nationaux
et par les grandes entreprises et les
grandes multinationales notamment de
l'industrie automobile de de la nièvre
tout simplement donc c'est grosso modo
ce qu'on me dit c'est vous si vous
voulez un grand prix de formule 1 vous
vous le payez et ben non
jusqu'à maintenant on l'a payé très cher
alors j'aime emmener ensuite en fait
c'est fort bien sûr j'aimerais faire la
fille très cher moi je suis en plus un
passionné de sport automobile et vous
nous parliez d'image du département
c'est ça c'est une formidable vitrine où
je me suis j'ai pas mal voyagé au monde
entier c'est clair le circuit de magny
cours d'une vitrine magnifique sauf que
le modèle économique est complètement à
revoir parce que
je crois qu'elle depuis cape une formule
1 ce circuit est redevenu rentable donc
il fait je le coup je pense
qu'effectivement c'est un gars c'est un
gâchis un gaspillage on n'a jamais
autant perdu conseil général a jamais
temps perdu d'argent uniquement pour
venir en permanence réinjecter de
l'argent dans la machine pour
effectivement avoir un grand prix qui
finalement est comme uniquement
économiquement parlant en dehors de
l'image ne rapportez pas grand chose
effectivement à nevers et ses environs à
l'opération on dit dans mon oreillette
pour vous at il touché votre micro sim
et en province faire disputer ginori
marcel stéphan votre votre position sur
le grand prix où on m'a effectivement
nous déjà ça dépend pas de la guerre
nationale la décision et puis bon ça a
coûté quand même aussi part au conseil
général bien sûr mais au conseil
régional également dé plusieurs millions
depuis quelques années et c'est vrai que
si on fait une étude était retombé au
niveau de la restauration de
l'hébergement et tout ça il faut
vraiment le le faire à fond
voir si vraiment financièrement c'est
rentable et je le pense pas moins
personnellement quand je vois les
millions du conseil général les
meilleurs du conseil régional je pense
que votre position si vous êtes élu au
sein du conseil général ce serait plutôt
de voter contre au tpo si vous avez deux
doit faire une étude approfondie déjà
sur sur toutes les retombées que sa
porte parce que bon pendant 1 pendant
quelques jours c'est vrai que les
commerces tout ça ça fonctionne
faudrait vraiment s'y pencher puis faire
une étude sérieuse
c'est un dossier compliqué pour les
serbes à doser communiqué mais pour
lequel aujourd'hui nous disposons de
l'ensemble des éléments moi je suis très
surpris des propos approximatifs qui
viennent d'être tenus
je dirais j'ai envie de dire à monsieur
marini et puis d'autres personnes ici
présentes promenez vous dans le vert
aller dans cette nième rurbaine pour
comprendre l'intérêt que représente ce
grand prix de magny cours et
éventuellement l'arrivée d'un grand prix
de formule 1 moi quand je vais prendre
un café je vais prendre un repas à
nevers on me demande alors où
est-ce que ça va revenir cette époque
exceptionnelle les études sont faites on
étude récente qui a été réalisé il ya
maintenant six mois après et qui
témoigne que les retombées sur
l'ensemble du territoire et ça dépasse
aliev puisque ça s'étend aux chairs et
l'allier c'est plus de 40 millions
d'euros avec une participation du
conseil général nous qu'on limite à
quelque chose qui pourrait être de
l'ordre de 2000 euros la difficulté
qu'il ya dans un projet comme celui-ci
qu'est ce que j'ai dit non par dominion
nom et de la difficulté qu'il y a dans
un dans un projet comme celui-ci c'est
que il ya une charge pour l'institution
mais à d'énormes retombées pour le
territoire
immédiatement c'est une réalité et si
vous allez rencontrer les entreprises de
magny cours
elles vous disent mais l'oeuf le nom de
magny cours et pour nous quelque chose
un moyen de communication énorme qui
nous fait exister à l'échelle
internationale vous le disiez monsieur
morinie et c'est vrai ça nous place elle
nous connecte d'une certaine manière au
monde et symboliquement c'est aussi
quelque chose qui nous permet qui nous
offre un peu de dignité et de fierté en
disant nous ne sommes pas rien ici il se
passe des choses exceptionnelles ont
construit des éléments de la voiture de
demain à magny cours aujourd'hui
il faut le savoir ce qui est témoigne
aussi que sur le territoire ruraux qui
ont une histoire qui ont un présent on a
aussi envie qu'ils aient une
un avenir industriel vraiment c'est
aussi de cela dont ça témoigne alors le
circuit aujourd'hui vous le disiez
fonctionne il est équilibré il gagne
même de l'argent
nous développons une activité autour de
trois aspects tout d'abord la
compétition avec l'ensemble de ce qui se
passe sur le circuit il fonctionne plus
de 300 jours par an ça n'est pas rien ce
sont plus de 35 personnes qui
travaillent 450 personnes travaillent
sur le pôle de magny cours qui est le
deuxième volet est le troisième volet
c'est un exemple en train
progressivement développé une activité
loisirs pour rentabiliser le nom
l'équipement les infrastructures de ce
site je vous coupe parce qu'on est vous
êtes en train de prendre le large
pascal brethes vous vouliez répondre et
puis on passera à un autre chapitre
mais répondre en disant que sur la
filière automobile oui il ya une vraie
elle cohérence très bien on est
absolument d'accord il faut développer
ce pôle
pas de problème mais en ce qui concerne
le grand prix combien de fois session
après session au noir est injecté des
millions et des millions en nous disant
ça ne sera que ça rassurez-vous et
finalement six mois après on nous en
remettait encore une petite couche alors
c'est vrai qu' on est un peu dubitatif
en disant que véritablement c'est la
panacée
ce grand circuit de france soyons clairs
pascal de mauraige vous êtes le leader
de l'opposition si après les élections
vous vous trouvez en position de décider
pour vous ça devient plus une priorité
en tout cas pas le grand prix de formule
1 pas nécessairement voilà qu'on soit
clair ici on avance sur votre vision du
département c'était un peu là dessus
qu'on était parti aussi avec un point
qui quelque chose qu'on entend beaucoup
dans la nuit a lancé la nièvre est elle
réellement les nivernais ce sont ils
réellement bourguignon par rapport au
fonctionnement et il ya une grande
nouveauté à venir
jean-philippe c'est bien sûr la grande
région oui bien sûr la grande région et
je reviens cette consultation que nous
avons fait récemment ou une courte
majorité ces 51% des nivernais bon même
si ça n'a pas valeur de sondage de
scientifiques se disent bourguignon il
en reste 40 9% qui se répartissent entre
le centre l'île de france et l'auvergne
pour certains il y en a même 3% qui
veulent être indépendants
donc quel est votre ça semble mal quelle
est votre position d'autant plus que le
mot nièvre revient dont de nombreuses
listes départementales
est-ce que c'est physique est ce que
c'est lié à la situation ou est-ce que
c'est lié peut-être puisque c'est notre
débat du jour à l'action du conseil
général jean morinie d'abord moi si vous
voulez enfin nous pensons sincèrement
que la nièvre les atouts que nous avons
envie d'adhérer
à la bourgogne et à la grande région
sauf que nous n'avons pas vraiment
l'impression d'avoir été géré de manière
faire en sorte que la lanière devenue le
parent pauvre le département isoler le
département rejeté et je pense
qu'effectivement vous avez une énorme
responsabilité
partout on devrait être en haut on a
paré au plus bas et partout on devrait
être plus bas on a parte on apparaît en
haut
6 il a si l'on veut faire de la nièvre
un territoire ambitieux nevers est quand
même la deuxième ville en termes
d'étudiants on avait bien dit on a des
atouts et des valeurs si on veut que nos
verts deviennent la troisième ville
après dijon après besançon
on a besoin de trouver des moyens de
d'avoir une politique plus cohérente
contient de ramener de le ramener à des
entreprises mais de ramener des emplois
sinon la nièvre trouvera pas son sommet
la synergie elle est dans la bourgogne
et dans la bourgogne franche comté ou
pour vous allez ailleurs la bourgogne
alain bocquet le truc c'était le sens
initial de la question françois diot
c'est un sujet n'est pas un sujet pour
vous et c'est un sujet dans l'action du
conseil général
plus largement c'est la réforme
territoriale qui en question la question
principale c'est pas les contours des
régions voilà la question c'est la
réforme territoriale qui est en cours et
le gouvernement aujourd'hui ne change
rien sur le fond de sa réforme
territoriale qui programment quoi la
création de super région taillé sur
mesure pour ce mener une concurrence
acharnée au niveau européen etc etc
1 la suppression des départements c'est
ce qui est dans les tuyaux avec
peut-être quand même le maintien de
certains départements ruraux lesquels
combien on sait pas quelles compétences
on sait pas non plus en tout cas ce qui
se discute en ce moment à l'assemblée
nationale c'est la suppression de la
clause de compétence générale qui
empêchera les départements de continuer
à intervenir sur les domaines qui eux
politiquement leur semblent les plus
importants on apprend aussi fin au japon
la prend pas on le sait que les
transports scolaires du morvan serait
régions gérées au niveau de la grande
ayons donc imaginer des transports du
morvan gérer à dijon où a besoin saut
c'est pas possible
et puis enfin maintien de des
départements dans certains dans
certaines zones rurales ça pose une
vraie question c'est l'égalité
républicaine
on a déjà pas droit en tant que
nivernais avoir le même système de santé
avoir le même système d'éducation à
avoir le même tissu industriel que le
reste de la france
on va y compris nous donner des
institutions particulière pour les
départements ruraux etc
moi je crains la création de
collectivités locales de seconde zone et
l'égalité républicaine
elle exige quand même que tout le monde
sur le territoire français est au
minimum droit aux mêmes aux homes et
institutions
donc cette réforme territoriale nous la
combattons et nous proposons
l'organisation d'un grand débat public
parce que ce qui est extraordinaire
c'est que les principaux concernés sont
mis complètement en dehors du coup c'est
à dire la population et les élus eux
mêmes
voilà et donc nous nous proposons
l'organisation d'un référendum à l'issue
d'un grand débat cartes sur table avec
la population sur cette réforme
territoriale vous avancez sur mes
chapitres c'est bien françois de la
réforme mais parce qu'elle demande
oui bien évidemment sur la réforme c'est
ainsi qu'en mai bongo bourgogne d'abord
oui c'est bien ce n'est pas un sujet
pour vous réalisez pas vraiment un sujet
sinon qu'effectivement cette grande
région
on ne sait pas trop bien finalement à
quoi elle va servir si elle va faire
elle devait être source d'économies on
en doute un petit peu on va dire que
c'est la capitale et des gens vous ne
serez pas plus loin de la capitale
tout à fait c'est assez sûr bon et après
effectivement c'est ses réformes
nous ne sommes pas contre des réformes
et la réforme qui a été proposé mais pas
à n'importe quel prix dans n'importe
quelles conditions
est ce normal aujourd'hui nous débattons
finalement de sujets qu'ils vont
concerner ce territoire départemental et
nous ne connaissons pas réellement les
compétences que nous devront exercer
ça ne sera voté que dans dix jours c'est
assez absurde et c'est extraordinaire
quand même
marcel stéphan parent dont marcel
stéphan
moi je bond dans le sens aujourd'hui on
les électeurs ils vont aller voter
le 22 mars et connaissent pas du tout
les compétences des conseillers
départementaux qu'ils vont lire mais qui
sera se faisant l'avocat du diable est
ce qu'ils les connaissaient déjà
qu'ils se rassurent nous non plus voilà
donc et ça c'est une première dans
l'histoire de france
je pense que c'est comme je disais tout
à l'heure c'est de l'amateurisme
vraiment là c'est une preuve de plus de
nos dirigeants c'est de dévitaliser tous
les échelons de proximité que sont les
communes et les départements au profit
de grandes intercommunalités minimum
vingt mille habitants imaginer ce que ça
donne dans le morvan et de grandes
régions
c'est à dire c'est une dévitalisation de
la démocratie locale et ça s'est passé
c'est pas les choix qu'ont fait les
français en 2012 tu ne vaux rien d'abord
et puis pas très joli nous répondra sur
la parcelle de 7 francs secondes pour
terminer ce que là ce que j'avais
entrepris
oui à l'amour ce qui est ce qu'on va
défendre nous bien sûr seul maintien des
départements puisque vous connaissez le
triptyque qu'on défend que marine le pen
défend ses les communes le département
l'état
voilà donc quand on est vraiment
attentif dès qu'on aura bien sûr ça sera
après les élections des compétences des
conseils départementaux de manière à ce
que ça disparaisse pas dans les années
qui viennent
parce qu'en fait la loutre n'eut pas
encore abouti on va le dire pour les
gens qui nous regardent la loi nôtre
c'est le nom de la loi qui est en train
de se déliter qui va déterminer les
élèves des compétences des conseils sur
lesquels les gens vont voter c'est la
première fois qu'on va envoyer des
électeurs élire des gens dont ce même
pas quels sont leurs compétences au
final ça va pas changer beaucoup
sa dépendance ici parce que justement
peut-être heures c'est un argument pour
le peuple manière peut-être qu'elle peut
grâce à cette décentralisation de grand
cette grande région
peut-être que la nièvre justement on
peut rebondir et revendiquée j'ai pas
une capitale des mathématiques de cette
grande région ça très joli sûr puisque
ça nous fait avancer sur la réforme
effectivement mais sur la forme et sur
les compétences des conseils généraux
parce que là on se projette sur ce
qu'ils avaient ce qu'il va y avoir c'est
quand même important de parler d'eux par
rapport aux compétences actuelles les
priorités que chacun que chacun veut y
mettre et ça on va y revenir mais pas
très jolie aventure vous vous étiez vent
debout vous aussi contre la réforme des
collectivités contre la suppression des
départements bien évidemment et je pense
modestement avoir contribué au maintien
des départements avec l'ensemble des
départements comme celui de la nièvre
qui ont combattu effectivement cette
suppression parce que qui aurait
représenté qui aurait représenté un
territoire comme celui d'agnès qu'il
n'ya pas le conseil général avec une
assemblée représentants de ces vingt
mille habitants c'est à dire à peu pâlot
poids de l'agglomération dijonnaise où
le poids des exonérations de besançon
c'est à dire pour effectivement prendre
en compte ce que représentent nos
territoires il fallait une institution
et c'est celle du conseil général qui
contrairement à ce que pensent certains
n'est pas ancien l'art est moderne en
soi parce qu'elle a beaucoup évolué
depuis depuis sa création il ya
maintenant 2 125 ans en france et sur le
continuerons avec 6 sur près de 6 ce
matin sur le sur le contenu des
compétences moi je voudrais rappeler
quand même puisqu'il y en a qui vont
être candidat
le rôle d'un conseiller général d'un
conseiller départemental à l'avenir
c'est à la fois de gérer l'institution
dans ses compétences mais aussi de
représenter le territoire est allé
défendre là où c'est nécessaire
là où les compétences ont exercé les
intérêts du territoire et moi j'ai
aucune difficulté à me présenter devant
les électeurs aujourd'hui en ne sachant
pas exactement quelles vont être les
compétences du conseil général parce que
je gérerai à la fois les compétences qui
sont confiées au conseil général
et depuis hier soir on sait qu'en gros
ça sera à peu près la seule chose les
collèges resteront départementaux les
routes resteront départementale les
transports scolaires sont gérées
localement comme ils le sont d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui à travers des syndicats
intercommunaux auquel le conseil général
à déléguer des compétences des cds et
donc ça sera passage en algérie
j'avais loin donc et puis on continuera
à faire ce que l'on fait jusqu'à
maintenant c'est aller défendre comme on
l'a fait sur le programme d'action sur
donné l'état et la région sur 2015-2020
défendre les intérêts de lanières
à l'échelle régionale échelle
départementale à l'échelle nationale et
à échelle européenne je vous coupe
patrice joly pour que tout le monde
réponde sur justement les compétences on
va partir du principe que globalement
les compétences parce qu'effectivement
c'est ce qu'on s'est un peu plus depuis
ces derniers jours voit à peu près resté
identique dans les compétences des
conseils généraux c'est à dire la
gestion du social des personnes âgées
transports scolaires les collèges
quelle est pour chacun d'entre vous si
il est en capacité parce que finalement
c'est aussi de ça qu'on doit parler les
choix qui devront être faits peut-être
plus sur certains sujets que sur
d'autres
pascal de maurage bien je crois que
toute façon on a une obligation à être
très attentif à tout ce qui est services
à la personne et notamment sur nos
associations d'aidé à domicile qui ont
d'énormes difficultés à exister sur nos
territoires et qui sont véritablement un
relais pour la mise en place d'un
certain nombre d'actions mais après tout
finalement et de même importance
importance sans un contexte de dotation
voir hier en baisse donc c'est pour ça
que je vous demande de faire des choix
et bien réussi nous avons des dotations
financières en baisse effectivement il
faudra serrer les boulons sur un certain
nombre de choses
peut-être peut-être sur une un service
de com qui est véritablement excessif et
qui pourraient être réduits puisque de
toute façon nous aurons à faire des
économies
marcel stéphan sur les compétences une
question précise
est ce que en capacité pour vous
l'action du conseil général devrait se
plier à un certain nombre de programmes
du front national par exemple la
préférence nationale
on sait par exemple que l'accueil des
mineurs étrangers c'est une compétence
des conseils généraux est ce que par
exemple c'est quelque chose que vous
supprimiez n'ont pas forcément parce que
les leviers dont dispose au niveau
département il faut s'en servir un petit
peu hors des chemins politiques
habituels
c'est à dire c'est à dire que l'on sait
que les leviers qu'on a sont locaux on
n'a pas la priorité nationale non là à
ce moment là parlons de priorité
départementale donc promesses la gestion
de la du social se fait dans le
département pour les gens du département
on est d'accord non mais à l'intérieur
de ça je vous pose la question du
programme du front national mois
précisément localement dans le respect
de la loi
voilà donc donc pas d'application
d'autres forcément a priori toute
manière je pense que on ne s'est pas
penché sur ces questions là encore
aujourd'hui ce qu'on se pose des
questions c'est le service d aide à la
personne comme madame de mauraige la l'a
dit si bien tout à l'heure et puis aussi
la gestion du patrimoine du conseil
général qu on a du mal à voir l'état du
patrimoine je pense que j'en profite
pour vous si vous pourriez nous donner
un petit coup de pouce à des candidats
qu'on fait des demandes pour avoir
l'état du patrimoine dont je parle de
château chinon principalement du village
de vacances de saint-agnant qu'à
l'abandon depuis trois ans je pense que
il y aurait une part une manne
financière mais il ya des de l'argent
qui pourrait rentrer
s'il y avait une gestion de ce
patrimoine différente parce que le fait
que ce patrimoine soit à l'abandon coûte
quand même puisqu'il faut le maintenir
en état
donc je pense qu'il est là il ya un gros
travail à faire on est donc d'accord
puisque on a des questions je vous pose
cette question dans cette saison parce
qu'on a eu des questions sur internet
qui sont tombés là dessus sur des
demandes par exemple de contrôler par
des gens qui sont manifestement vos
électeurs de contrôle plus fort d'action
de contrôle et de deux d'encadrement
beaucoup plus forte de certaines aides
sociales donc on est d'accord que pour
vous c'est pas nécessaire et social ces
régies par des lois tout ça où ils ont
accès ou pas d'accord voilà me fera
respecter bien sûr les villes à main
merci j'ai dormi sur les compétences
parce que on a entendu pascal morès dire
attention la communication par exemple
tout à l'heure moi j'ai entendu dire
aussi que vous insistiez sur l'image du
département donc clair il faut il va
falloir que on rendre encore plus
attractif le département de la nièvre du
département à 17 départements de france
dont la population est en constante
régression
il faut effectivement on veut trouver
des budgets dans une riche des richesses
qui baisse de la dotation de l'état
baisse des droits de mutation ce qui
montre bien la crise immobilière ou que
traverse le département
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
devons changer notre méthode de gestion
apporter plus de rigueur
avoir une raison plus une gestion plus
maîtriser plus raisonnée plus
raisonnable
retrouvez effectivement du budget pour
pouvoir investir dans le marketing
départementale faire revenir les jeunes
investir là on est la compétence du
conseil général
investir dans l'éducation on a on a un
visage qui est qui marche très très bien
continuer c'est cette une
c'est une image de marque au niveau
national il faut implanter un ut il faut
implanter une faculté au moins une
première année de droit il faut ramener
les jeunes formés les eaux il faut
ramener les entreprises
il faut re motiver les gens au moins
pour éviter cet exode
et cette déperdition de population et ça
c'est des compétences du conseil général
et si effectivement elle ne change pas
falloir se jeter à fond dedans parce
qu'elle demeurait jour d'autres juste la
parole parce qu'effectivement c'était un
clin d'oeil quand vous parlez de
communication je suppose que c'était
communication des services de
communication s'était pas l'image du
département voilà c'est vrai que il faut
trouver le juste équilibre entre
finalement faire un département
attractif ou comme dit monsieur il faut
ramener de la population des jeunes il
faut que les gens s'approprient ce
département après il faut peut-être mais
là on va peut-être dans les propositions
ensuite
donc on développera plus être plus loin
mais il faut effectivement que ce
département qui n'est pas connu
quand on dit qu'on est de la nièvre bon
ce qu'il ya un petit temps d'arrêt on ne
sait pas trop où se trouve cette nièvre
et pourtant elle a des atouts elle a des
atouts qui sont probablement pas assez
mis en valeur ou mal mis en valeur on
traduit une réponse et puis après on
fera un tour de propositions un petit
peu concrètes pour tout le monde avant
de passer à la politique pure et dure si
vous permettez parler des compétences
sans parler des moyens ça aucun sens
déjà moi je maintiens que les
compétences des départements sont
attaqués aujourd'hui puisque l'objectif
est l'esprit de la réforme territoriale
c'est de dévitaliser les communes et les
dettes les départements au profit de
grandes intercommunalités et de grandes
régions c'est ce qui se discute
aujourd'hui à l'assemblée nationale et
ensuite du point de vue budgétaire
l'état programme une saignée de 28
milliards d'euros d'ici 2017 dans les
moyens qui sont alloués aux
collectivités c'est à dire 30 % 30 % de
baisses de dotations d'état aux
collectivités d'ici à 2017 pour le
département de la nièvre
quand 2014 ces trois millions d'euros de
dotations d'état en moins sachant que
l'état doit déjà 96 millions d'euros au
département de la nièvre au titre des
compensations transfert qui n'ont pas
été compensées etc etc
donc ces politiques d'austérité de
restriction budgétaire de baisse aveugle
des dépenses publiques pour des
départements fragile comme le nôtre
c'est criminel
et c'est criminel pour les pour
l'économie locale puisque par exemple
dans le bâtiment et les travaux publics
ces 600 emplois qui ont été supprimés
dans le département de la nièvre depuis
le mois de juillet dernier et 70
apprentis parce que les collectivités
représentent 75 % des investissements
publics donc asphyxier les collectivités
s'est asphyxié toute l'économie locale
et donc il faut se battre contre ça il
nous n'avons par exemple propositions
très concrètes qu'on a fait à la région
bourgogne
c'est aujourd'hui il me semble que les
intérêts de la dette du conseil général
représente 3% des dépenses de
fonctionnement donc 3% qui vont aux
banquiers qui sont en train d'organiser
l'évasion fiscale 1 on a vu hsbc et bien
il faut refuser de payer ses intérêts de
la dette ce sera une maigre contribution
de la finance au développement des
territoires ruraux
parce que d'abord je voulais simplement
finalement rejoindre monsieur encore là
dessus non non non mais vous rejoindre
au moins sur le fait que ce que l'on va
pas pouvoir investir dans nos
collectivités parce qu'on va nous
demander une contribution tél et bien
c'est moins de développement local et
moins d'investissement local donc il
faut rompre avec les politiques
d'austérité
vous dites oui alléluia une vision de la
gestion plus pragmatique pas idéaliste
on va faire répond pas très joli là
dessus sur la gestion je vous propose
avant de passer sur la d7 gestion
d'abord sur les six ont la critique sur
la communication une butée de
communication depuis le président de
conseil général n'a pas augmenté alors
si effectivement ça apparaît mieux c'est
que ça a dû être plus efficace et c'est
tant mieux donc c'est de la bonne
gestion des fonds publics je voudrais
aussi redire aussi sortant la sinistrose
notre département est redevenu attractif
depuis 15 ans aujourd'hui nous
accueillons plus de personnes qu'il n'en
part de notre territoire départemental
et si nous perdons encore de la
population c'est ce qu'on appelle le
solde positif le solde naturel qui la
différence entre les naissances et les
décès c'est tout notre département est
attractif en particulier la puisaye
madame de moreuil je vous l'apprends
peut-être votre votre territoire fait
partie des territoires du département
attractif
content de vous l'entendre attractif
donc non je veux dire par là qu'il faut
connaître aussi et dire les choses
correspondant à la réalité de notre
territoire si on veut éclairer les
électeurs et surtout à partir d'un
diagnostic correct mettre en place des
politiques publiques adaptées
s'agissant de la priorité pour ce qui me
concerne l'économie il développe non
bien évidemment
à travers deux choses ce que fait le
conseil général en terme d'animation du
territoire dgt aide à organiser les
filières à faire en sorte que les les
entreprises ce soit celle du secteur du
bois celle de 2,2 de la métallurgie
travaillent ensemble c'est ce que nous
avons fait en soutenant le pôle bois de
la charité sur loire en soutenant le
pôle bois de 2,2 de sougy en soutenant
également le pôle de magny cours et
aider à travailler ensemble qui permet
de développer l'activité et qui a permis
pour l'exemple de magny cours d'un de
construire cette formule 4 qui
aujourd'hui se vente à travers le monde
entier
il ya d'autres choses la question des
infrastructures on va chercher
effectivement les moyens à l'extérieur
d'intervenir
ça a été dit là 77 aujourd'hui va se
terminer on le sait il n'y aura plus
d'arrêts du chantier jusqu'à son
achèvement la limite du territoire
départemental
sur la question des services peut-être
le dernier point parce que c'est
important sur l'association
c'est à la fois l'aide aux personnes
âgées les rôles aide aux personnes
handicapées
l'aide aux personnes qui sont en
difficulté par rapport à l'emploi ce que
je veux dire par là que les contrôles
existent au sein d'action départementale
chaque mois je signe des ordres de
récupération des indus
j'envoie des courriers au procureur de
la république pour qu'il y ait des
sanctions pénales lorsque
d'effectivement des aides sont accordés
de manière irrégulière des gens qui ont
triché anges mais je n'ai aucun état
d'âme à le faire parce que je crois à la
solidarité est un droit mais il ne faut
pas que ce soit dévoyé
c'est une question aussi d'acceptabilité
par l'ensemble de nos concitoyens
ce sont deux c'est de l'argent public ce
sont des impôts derrière ça mais à la
solidarité mme apparaître aussi adroit
on peut les uns les autres un jour
avoir besoin propres agents publics
millions d'euros de crédits d'impôt
compétitivité emploi comme on dit qui
ont été données aux grandes entreprises
nivernaise sans aucun sens aucune
contrepartie sur sur la création
d'emplois dont il faut exiger le
remboursement ou parce que l'on essaie
de gérer le temps pour tout le monde et
marcel stéphan parce qu'elle demeurait
je suis très en retard et il ya avec un
peu d'humour un candidat l'élection a
envoyé un tweet en disant à un moment
donné ce qui à un moment donné où les
candidats font des propositions
donc je vous propose de nous faire
quelques propositions sur un mandat
éventuellement commencer par pascal de
mauraige qui est beaucoup plus en retard
que vous aimeriez s'était fait insulter
simplement je voulais sur la filière
bois je trouve que quand même votre
majorité a manqué de courage
nous aurions pu avoir un débat au sein
de l'assemblée sur sardy les epiry pour
ou contre je pense que le dossier était
d'une telle ampleur qu'on aurait pu
avoir ce débat je le regrette
après la question c'était des
propositions et donc quelles
propositions concrètes qui fait que les
électeurs de lanières pourrait valoir
des propositions
si nous arrivons commandes bien sûr que
l'on demandera quand même une expertise
tant d'années géré par une même majorité
ça suppose aussi qu'on puisse poser les
choses aient regardé je pense qu'il
faudrait avoir une véritable politique
d'accueil de nouvelles activités
nouvelles entreprises en ayant par
exemple des outils de développement qui
soit regroupé des structures de
promotion qui soit présente dans des
salons et pour faire connaître justement
ce département et pour marquer son
attractivité
ce qui signifie qu'elle n'est pas le cas
comment ça signifie que ça n'est pas le
cas actuellement
il ya des choses qui sont faites mais ne
m'habille elles ne sont pas suffisantes
et puis je pense que de toute façon il
n'ya que la création d'activités qui
nous permettra demain de faire face
justement aux compétences et aux
compétences qui vont nous être imposée
et surtout dans le domaine social
autrement nous n'aurons pas les moyens
de faire face à ses compétences
donc il faut aussi recentrer sur une
économie locale évidemment les circuits
courts etc
et je pense qu'on a tout intérêt de
passer d'un cercle vicieux un cercle
vert
voilà la recette est fait pour vous nous
on n'est pas des livreurs de promesses
parce que quand tu tombes des
propositions c'est des promesses est bon
au niveau emploi et tout ça on n'a pas
les leviers localement pour faire
revenir des entreprises de leur connerie
fait partie des compétences
oui est ce qu'aujourd'hui il ya des
entreprises qui vont se réinstaller dans
la nièvre ne le pense pas sincèrement
c'est pas nous qui disposons de ces
leviers là il va falloir protéger un
petit peu les entreprises si on veut qui
relocalisent en nièvre ou en france tout
simplement
et puis c'est vrai que localement
je disais à l'heure une meilleure
gestion du patrimoine faudra en faire un
audit et puis voir comment on peut
améliorer les choses de façon à les
rentabiliser
et puis les promesses ma foi on les fera
une fois qu'on aura réuni tous ses
renseignements on pourra faire enfin
enfin des promesses pour l'instant on
fait aucune promesse
j'aimerais bien évidemment il faut
profiter de la richesse notre
environnement et la nièvre est riche
effectivement son environnement naturel
on parlait la filière bois massif et
démanteler la filière bois il faut
développer les circuits courts les
arbres sont coupés à la nième mais sont
ils sont fixes portés ailleurs pour être
travaillée un emploi dans la nièvre dans
la filière bois en génère indirectement
7 ou 8 mai à lire du département il faut
ramener effectivement redévelopper les
circuits de proximité c'est pareil pour
l'élevage pour la culture pour les
maraîchers
on transforme on élève des bovins de
charolais et comme une race mondialement
connus où furent les élèves beaucoup
dans le morvan
on va les tuer ailleurs on va les
transformer ailleurs pourquoi ne pas
justement profiter de la richesse
biologique naturel le département pour
ne serait-ce que le proposer localement
dans les collèges
on est dans l'est dans les écoles c'est
s'est pas fait je crois que s'il ya une
expérience à caunes qui était faite
récemment mais voilà c'est sait profiter
de ces choses là maintenant on veut
parler aussi des propositions sur le
social la gauche n'est pas le monopole
du social
effectivement il faut il faut retrouver
du budget je pense que peu des lecteurs
savent que le conseil général est très
généreux avec les dépenses publiques
chaque année le loup une subvention de
plus de 100000 euros
l'association des anciens
conseils généraux pour quoi faire nous
c'est vrai ou pas monsieur jolie nous
cet argent là on peut être on pourrait
très bien l'utiliser pour faire autre
chose pour le social parce que la salle
de la solidarité c'est une chose c'est
un coup il faut y voi avoir les moyens
et je pense que tous autour de la table
et là aucun d'entre nous n'a envie de
laisser les gens à côté d'un chemin au
bord des routes
on est prêt pour l'accompagner mais il
faut des moyens et pouvoirs les moyens
il faut une économie
voilà gestion on va faire répond patrice
joly pascal une question est d'abord
françois diouf n'est pas très joli
conclura sur eux sur sa partie
proposition avant qu'on passe à la
suivante quand on dit proposition c'est
les propositions sérieuses pour sortir
le département l'ornière voilà
l'industrie l'industrie je disais 6000
emplois industriels supprimés depuis
est ce qu'on continue il ya encore trois
mille emplois industriels dans le rien
que dans l'automobile
bon il faut faire front avec les
salariés les syndicats et les élus
locaux pour faire valoir les
propositions qu'on les salariés on
disait en vie mais les salariés ils ont
fait des contre-propositions
il avait des propositions de
développement pour leur propre
entreprise et c'est les actionnaires
japonais qui ont flingué l'entreprise
donc il faut imposer d'autres choix et
je pense que la proposition qui avait
été faite d'une grande table ronde alors
pas une table ronde pour discuter une
table ronde pour créer un rapport de
force avec avec avec ses entreprises
dans dix ans vous avez une
responsabilité dans notre territoire
c'est ça que devrait imposer le conseil
général pour la sidérurgie pareil jeudi
les aciéries d'imphy si leur avenir est
entre les mains de monsieur mittal gens
donnent pas cher voilà il faut cinq ans
pour faire un bon sidérurgiste
compétence générale l'augmentation des
lits des conseillers généraux pas pour
gérer les cimetières
on élit des conseillers généraux pour
créer des rapports de forces pour créer
une dynamique de territoire et un
conseiller général
il a une légitimité démocratique ensuite
sur la santé désertification médicale
dans le département nous nous proposons
des centres de santé publique avec des
médecins salariés c'est pas la même
chose que les maisons médicales les
maisons médicales c'est les communes
elles payent les bâtiments pour une
médecine pour des médecins libéraux qui
restent isolées étaient là non là c'est
des centres de santé publique avec des
médecins salariés
adossé à nos hôpitaux publics de
proximité qu'il faut donc défendre et
nous on propose de les mettre sous
protêt
action citoyenne parce que quand même
quand on aura plus d'hôpital à
château-chinon et decize et à clamecy
comment s'étonner qu'on perde de la
population on faire une ferme et une
maternité c'est dire à nos enfants et
aux jeunes vous n'avez plus votre place
ici donc des centres de santé publics la
filière bois tout le monde en parle ceci
dit je prémery par exemple il ya eu des
industries importantes de la chimie du
bois je vous coupe françois dur parce
qu'il ya des gens qui attendent pour
répondre vous vous demandez les
propositions je rajoute fin finalement
quand même l'électrification de la ligne
vers dijon
c'est un formidable outil de
développement du fret et c'est un projet
de développement durable parce que c'est
économique sociale écologique et
heureusement que les que les élus
communistes sont là à la région depuis
plusieurs mandats pour gagner
inscriptions au contrat de plan
etat-région ça vient d'être fait et
bravo à jean paul pinaud vous avez
accordé des propositions bien garnie de
réponse de pascal amoureuse et puis
ensuite parce qu'ils sont la
désertification médicale je veux dire
que vous faites un petit peu une erreur
il n'y a pas dans les maisons de santé
que des médecins c'est des maisons
pluridisciplinaires donc les élus
effectivement au fait l'effort
d'accompagner ces professionnels de
santé pour faire une offre de soins qui
soit adaptée sur leur territoire dans
les bâtiments sont vides on risque de
change regrette le chez moi ils sont pas
vides ou sinon c'est vide où il y assure
à 15 kilomètres l'un de l'autre
deux maisons de santé avec une quinzaine
de professionnels de santé à l'intérieur
c'est une demande des médecins
d'ailleurs d'être salarié parce qu'une
jeune femme qui de maisons médicales
entre diverses voilà c'est comme pour
les centres de santé c'est pas par et
les centres de santé
ils sont salariés et par exemple une
jeune femme médecin l'adroit congé de
maternité elle ya droit quand on est en
médecins ayant droit là il faudra regard
très large sur le sujet et dire à chaque
territoire à chaque secteur
sa proposition la plus adaptée pour
rendre service aux habitants dans la
nièvre se laissant de son dragon des
propositions juste un mot quand même par
rapport à ce que disait monsieur morinie
parce que je suis un peu surpris les
candidats sous la bannière nièvre à
venir et il fait de la politique un peu
à l'ancienne
parce que en laissant entendre qu'on
verse 100 mille euros à la zone conseil
général pour faire honte c'est quoi tout
ça paraît pas très clair
m c'est joli et de jeter l'opprobre de
manière indigne
je veux dire on ne peut pas faire ça on
n'a pas le droit ni vis-à-vis de
l'adversaire qu'on a en face de soi ou
du concurrent ni vis-à-vis de la
population
c'est très simple depuis 1992 il y à un
dispositif de retraite pour les
conseillers généraux
il n'existait pas avant 1992 il existait
quelque chose dans ce cadre là qui a été
légalisé et tout ça se fait de manière
très claire est sous contrôle de la
chambre régionale des comptes
il ya aucun problème donc vraiment
évitons ça le débat politique ne
gagneront rien et la démocratie encore
moins je voyais par rapport aux
compositions qui ont été évoqués bien
évidemment la filière bois l'eau si je
veux le redire ses 1600 emplois
aujourd'hui comme dans ce département ça
n'est pas rien on veut essayer de la
conforter de la développer c'est un
élément important
l'agriculture maintenir un nombre
d'exploitations agricoles un nombre
d'agriculteurs aussi important en
soutenant les agriculteurs est ce que
vous savez qu'aujourd'hui une
exploitation sur deux qui s'installe
dans ce département est une exploitation
soutenu par le seul conseil général en
dehors des aides de l'état conseil
général est impliqué nous venons
d'intervenir récemment cession à
l'unanimité et madame de mauraige pour
reprendre la ferme du maroc est une
exceptionnelle vitrine de l'agriculture
équiterre en difficulté quel est le
besoin à la fois de travaux mais surtout
d'un projet nous sommes en train de
travailler avec les professionnels pour
justement valorisé ce qui est notre
fierté c'est effectivement cet élevage
cet élevage charolais nivernais parmi
les propositions le tourisme bien
évidemment encore un potentiel important
à développer et nous on a comme attendu
on peut encore faire plus
et comment faire pour développer
l'économie locale c'est de faire en
sorte que les cônes que l' épargne de
nos concitoyens nivernais sert à
financer le développement économique
aujourd'hui il faut savoir que nous
avons à peu près huit fois moins
d'emprunts que nous avons d'epargne
c'est à dire c'était par la caisse
qu'elle fait va financer des régions
autres nous allons mettre en place un
dispositif visant à permettre une
rémunération ses dix ans de l'epargne
local qui permettra à financer les
projets parce qu'on sait que les banques
sont beaucoup trop frileuse ça c'est un
projet clair on sait qu'ils aient
dispositif aujourd'hui à travers des
plateformes de financement qui vont nous
permettre de réaliser ça mais surtout un
des gros projets c'est d'améliorer le
confort de nos concitoyens et redonner
du pouvoir d'achat en diminuant la
facture énergétique nous avons un projet
de
mettre en place à partir de maintenant
et pour les cinq années qui viennent un
projet de rénovation de l'habitat qui
passerait de 800 logements rénovés cette
année à 4000 logements et ensuite quatre
mille logements pendant de nombreuses
années
et comme on n'a pas d'argent
effectivement publique supplémentaire
mobilisés on a trouvé le modèle parce
qu'on l'a construit parce que c'est un
effort partagé avec les professionnels
de la filière du bâtiment que qui était
évoqué on l'a trouvé les moyens globaux
pour voir le faire sans qu'il y ait
d'intervention supplémentaire publics
ont à travers simplement les économies
d'énergie à travers les réductions
fiscales qu'on peut obtenir
derrière ça c'est 30 à 50 millions
d'emplois je vous coupe parce que
pendant 30 à 50 millions par an de
travaux est ce qui correspond à peu près
à trop 600 et 800 emplois de vous couper
ça va être les informations de midi dans
une poignée de secondes et on se
retrouve juste après a tout de suite